I have to ask you because you work at
the interplay of uh the machine
and the natural world is there a good
definition for you of what is life
what is a living organism
I think like 440 million years ago there
were all these plants
that
[Music]
um
the cyanobacteria I believe actually
that that God that that was like the
first Extinction right there were six
five extinctions we are apparently the
sixth we are in the eye of the storm we
are in the sixth Extinction we are going
to be extinct as we speak I mean death
is upon us whether we want to admit it
or not and actually they found in
Argentina and in in you know various
places around the world they found these
spores of the first plants that existed
on the planet and they
emerged out of this cyanobacteria where
the first of course and then they found
these spore-based plants
and because they didn't have seeds or
only Sports the spores became sort of
the fossils by which we've come to known
of their existence
and because of these Sports we know that
this first Extinction existed
but this Extinction is actually what
enabled plants to redirect right so the
death of these first plants because they
clinked to the rocks and they they
generated a ton of phosphorus that went
into the ocean by
clinging to the Rocks like 60 times more
phosphorus than without them and then
all this phosphorus basically choked the
oceans and made them super cold and a
without oxygen aoxic and then and then
we lost the plant kingdom and then
because of the death of these first
plants they actually enriched the soil
and created nutrients for these new
plants to come to the planet
um and those planets had like more
sophisticated vein systems and they were
moving beyond spores to seeded plants
Etc and flowering plants and so in a way
you one mass extinction sort of LED
in in the the
or division period sort of led to Life
as we know it and where would we be
without plants in a way so I I think
that death is very much part of life and
through that definition that kind of
planetary
wide definition in the context of
hundreds of millions of years
um life gains a completely new sort of a
new light and that's where
that's when the particles become a wave
right where humans are we are not alone
and we are here because of those plants
right so I think death is is very much
part of life so in the context of you
know the redwood tree perhaps you know
life is defined as uh 10 generations and
through the lens of a bacteria perhaps
life is defined as a millisecond and
perhaps through the lens of of an AGI
life is defined as all of human
civilization and so I think it really is
a question of
um
this time scale again the time scale and
the organism the life form that's asking
the question through which we can answer
what is life